je voudrais d'abord rappeler à Messieurs
les messieurs les ministres ici on est
au Sénat et qu'on n'est pas là pour
faire le match retour ce qui s'est passé
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale on est au Sénat on
va repartir sur des bases saines et je
pense que il faut arrêter et si vous
souhaitez que le débat se passe bien je
pense qu'il faut arrêter avec ces
provocations voilà je pense que ça c'est
des choses qu'il fallait peut-être
peut-être appeler sur la proposition du
groupe CRCE je pense que le groupe a
tout à fait raison de dénoncer ce
corsetage et d'ailleurs je constate que
c'est quelque chose qui a été signalé
par un certain nombre d'élus de la
majorité
sénatorial qui dénonçait effectivement
ce corps se tâche ce choix du
gouvernement de limiter de limiter le
débat et je rappelle également
qu'Elisabeth borne nous avait promis un
temps un texte dédié elle nous avait dit
que on aurait un test dédié
qu'évidemment elle ne passerait pas par
ce projet de loi de finances de sécurité
sociale rectificatif on voit on voit le
résultat mais alors pourquoi pourquoi
cette urgence pourquoi ce passage en
force pourquoi ce festival des mensonges
pourquoi cette contrainte du débarque
parlementaire en fait tout simplement
pourquoi refuser le débat pourquoi parce
que vous ne voulez tout simplement pas
qu'on parle du fond vous ne voulez pas
parler de votre projet dans le fond les
raisons réelles de ce projet destruction
des services publics destruction de vos
de nos acquis sociaux toujours moins
pour nos communs toujours moins et
toujours plus plutôt pour le pour le
privé c'est ça votre projet c'est le
projet de la de la finance c'est les
projets d'une d'une retraite uniquement
gérée par le privé et puis pour les
autres pour le reste pour les petites
gens et bien il y aura les miettes voilà
votre votre projet mais évidemment vous
ne voulez pas qu'on en parle et bien on
aura et nous on souhaite avoir ce temps
du débat le temps qu'il faudra et il y a
une responsabilité ici qui sera la
responsabilité du gouvernement qui a
décidé de limiter ce débat
[Musique]